[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture une émission pour
vous présenter à les projets culturels
yvelinois au programme aujourd'hui une
exposition temporaire est ouverte à
versailles brindas vous propose de
découvrir une dizaine d'artistes tous
les quinze jours pour une trentaine
d'exposants au total au programme à
peinture sculpture ou encore
photographie la batterie à guyancourt
organisé un spectacle surprise pour
fêter la réouverture dans ce conte ou
encore ciné concert 80 personnes ont été
accueillies à l'auditorium pour la
soirée un concert annonciateur de
nombreux autres rendez vous et puis le
château de croatie présente sa nouvelle
exposition tableaux de maîtres des
reproductions de la joconde marilyn ou
encore un napoléon bonaparte
entièrement réalisée en lego et je vous
le disais en titre fermé depuis plus de
six mois les lieux culturels ont pu
rouvrir mercredi à 19 mai date à
laquelle l'exposition temporaire brun
d'arre a ouvert à ses portes à
versailles car td en kit des antiquaires
au programme peinture sculpture ou
encore photographie un reportage de
bérangère bourgoin ouverte et accessible
gratuitement pour tous depuis le 19 mai
et jusqu'au 30 juin l'exposition brin
d'herbe est le fruit d'une collaboration
entre les deux sociétés air sync
business et brun de france un roulement
tous les quinze jours permettra à une
trentaine d'artistes d'y être exposée
sur six semaines on va représenter 33
artistes donc trois ans 33 artistes qui
vont défiler on aime bien appeler ça un
défilé d'art puisque sur trois sessions
de 15 jours chacune
onze artistes sur chaque session va
pouvoir
voilà montrer leur présenter leur
travail au programme peinture sculpture
photographie les artistes seront
présents et vont pouvoir en semaine ou
le week-end venir à la rencontre des
visiteurs
moi c'est ça que j'aime dans les arts
les oeuvres c'est que moi je les ai
faites
mais chaque personne qui les regardent
va se les approprier et va s'imaginer ce
qu'il a envie en fonction de son vécu en
fonction de ses émotions
je pense que ça va donner un vrai élan
de liberté à tout le monde aux artistes
aux visiteurs et danser une initiative
qu'on peut vraiment que saluer cette
exposition sera mise au profit du
service pédiatrique de l'hôpital mignot
l'une des artistes que je représente
leur simoneau a créé une jolie structure
et nous allons faire une oeuvre
collaborative
nous vendrons des morceaux de ruban que
les gens pourront déposer sur cette
structure est avec cet argent décolleté
récolté nous irons ré investir dans du
matériel d'art supplémentaires auprès de
nos partenaires pour tout le monde soit
gagnant
et on offrira tout ça au service
pédiatrie au mois de juillet plusieurs
événements vont être organisées comme
des vernissages chaque vendredi de début
de session des nocturnes dès que le
protocole sanitaire le permettra ou
encore trop soirée dégustation vins et
fromages et pour fêter la réouverture du
19 mai également la batterie à
guyancourt a organisé un spectacle
surprise donc mercredi 19 mai à 19h au
programme danses concerts contes ou
encore ciné concert 80 personnes ont été
accueillies le temps de la soirée à
l'auditorium un concert annonciateur de
nombreux autres rendez vous nous étions
sur place les images de bixente mais
rien senti steben la batterie a retrouvé
son public mercredi 19 mai les équipes
l'attendait depuis des mois un spectacle
surprise a été organisée à l'auditorium
objectif fêter la réouverture et marquer
le coup l'événement a été improvisée à
la dernière minute face à l'incertitude
un spectacle d'une heure et demie monter
en une semaine on est dans
l'improvisation c'est vrai dire le
décret sorti que ce matin un nul
permettant réellement et donc oui la
ville à la ville a souhaité marquer le
coup
on a on a des spectacles
par exemple samedi qu'ils sont qui sont
dans la programmation officielle mais là
on voulait être au rendez-vous de cette
date importante
au programme contes improvisation danse
ou encore ciné concert une douzaine
d'artistes s'est succédé sur la scène
dans des univers est-il différent
c'est le cas du groupe la brise du
mammouth prévenu une semaine avant et
face à l'incertitude
ils n'ont pu répéter qu'une fois avant
le spectacle les artistes étaient
pourtant ravi de performer à nouveau
devant un public
ça fait plaisir c'est vrai que ça fait
ça fait longtemps donc ça fait un peu
bizarre tout début le premier morceau on
fait un peu rouillé quoi mais ouais
c'est vraiment sympa quoi de pouvoir
rejouer enfin je crois que nous on avait
envie de rejouer mais je pense que les
gens aussi avait envie de le revoir un
peu de groupes en live donc tout le
monde était motivé protocole sanitaire
oblige et la salle a ouvert avec 35% de
la jauge 80 spectateurs ont été
accueillis sur place
côté programmation d'autres concerts et
événements sont prévus 4 juin
effectivement il ya un duo avec jean
marie machado très grand pianiste aussi
aux jardins de l'ermitage le soir et le
lendemain matin le samedi 5 juin une
conférence circonférence donc à
l'auditorium de l'école de musique par
andré minvielle sur l'idée de désaxant
dans le monde
leur lien avec les musiques le 5 juin
après midi un bal sera organisé au
jardin de l'héritage d'autres spectacles
à venir dans les yvelines le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vous propose
de découvrir la création théâtrale dans
la foule inspirée du roman de laurent
mauvignier le spectacle dévoile une
europe en crise au travers de
témoignages de supporters de foot
les représentations auront lieu les 2 et
3 juin à 19 heures au petit théâtre de
la scène nationale à saint quentin en
yvelines m et puis la royale factory à
versailles présente la belle-mère un
spectacle humoristique d' isabelle parsy
dans lequel elle décrit une femme qui ne
reculerait devant rien pour garder son
fils un spectacle d'une heure quinze
à découvrir les 4 5 et 6 juin si vous
vous promenez dans les rues op
vous pourrez découvrir l'exposition les
quais dans ce sont des treize panneaux
de silhouette de danseuse en plexiglas
de l'artiste alpiq war reynald et zapata
ils sont répartis sur les quais rive
gauche et célia gâte son goût vous êtes
avec nous ce soir pour en parler windsor
bonsoir plus que ça une simple
exposition c'est aussi un jeu concours
oui jusqu'au 6 juin prochain la ville du
pecq le récompensera la photo qui mettra
le mieux en valeur les silhouettes des
danseuses en clic sea glace plus d'une
centaine de personnes ont déjà participé
vous le voyez un sur ces images on a des
petites filles qui prennent la même pose
que des danseuses ou encore des photos
prises à différents moments de la
journée
le but c'est d'amener de l'art dans la
rue le faire sortir la culture des lieux
clos de façon à ce que pendant la
période de confinement notamment puisque
les gens ne pouvaient pas aller au
spectacle ne pouvait pas aller dans les
salles d'expo façon à amener un peu de
un peu de vie culturelle à l'extérieur
dessalement donc comment peut participer
à ce jeu concours
et bien c'est très simple il suffit de
poster une jusqu'à cinq photos maximum
en participant sur votre compte facebook
ou instagram en taguant les quais danse
ou ville du pecq puis le de s'abonner au
portefeuille ce book de la ville et de
l'artiste et la salle de spectacles de
qe3
propos il était d'impliquer un maximum
de gens y compris les services
techniques de la ville y compris y
compris le public je voulais pas quelque
chose de passif pourquoi avoir choisi du
plexiglas célia c'est un peu étonnant
comme matériau oui et bien en plus ce
reynald de zapata fait normalement de la
peinture mais pour cette exposition il
ne voulait pas utiliser des surfaces
classiques comme la toile ou le bois ce
matériau qui est bas qui est utilisé
depuis un an surtout pour faire une
barrière et le terme de barrière est un
pas très positif je me suis dit on va le
détourner on va en faire une oeuvre
d'art ce qui nous manque en plus
cruellement depuis un an et au lieu de
prendre la silhouette intérieur on avait
choisi de découper cette silhouette
comme ce danseur ces artistes qui nous
ont manqué pendant tout ce temps là en
fait on l'enlève et on garde le cadre
qui est autour
les résultats seront communiqués
vendredi 11 juin le gagnant remportera
une découpe des ballerines en plastique
gas dans un format d'environ 50 cm fait
par l'artiste rénale zapata et bien
merci célia gâte son goût d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir
la joconde marilyn ou encore bonaparte
franchissant le grand saint bernard des
toiles des tableaux de maîtres bien
connu ils sont exposés actuellement au
château de croatie particularité ces
tableaux ont été entièrement fait en
lego sur place bérengère bourgoin s'est
rendu là bas regarder une exposition de
tableaux de grands maîtres
entièrement construit en briques lego
c'est l'exposition qui est actuellement
proposée au château chan aurier à
croissy sur seine
c'est une exposition sur les tableaux de
maîtres voilà donc c'est vraiment une
exposition où les gens vont pouvoir
s'asseoir étudier des tableaux et
regarder les tableaux comme dans un vrai
musée quoi sur place pas de surprise la
plupart des oeuvres présentées sont des
tableaux bien connu alors dans cette
exposition vous avez une trentaine de
tableaux donc en bas vous avez plus le
classique
l'impressionnisme bien sûr puisqu'on est
à croissy vous allez retrouver le
tableau de renoir est au dessus à
l'étagé du dessus vous allez retrouver
un petit peu plus de modernité avec le
pop art notamment et andy warhol
[Musique]
toutes les oeuvres ont été réalisées à
croissy l'exposition a représenté mis
200 heures de travail et sept cent
quarante mille briques à côté de chaque
toile vous avez un cartel qui explique
l'oeuvre et le nombre de briques lego
utilisé pour l'oeuvre
et puis le temps passé pour la montée un
parcours de jeu est prévu pour les
enfants une exposition est proposée
jusqu'au 18 juillet mais attention la
réservation est obligatoire pour pouvoir
venir visiter et parmi les autres
expositions à venir du 21 au 30 mai
venez découvrir à l'exposition d'audrey
cavalloni l'artiste présentera ses
dernières créations poumon en fleurs et
des liens qui emprisonne des liens qui
libèrent au programme couture textile et
descend ça se passera à la maison des
bonheurs de magny les hameaux
et puis les ateliers à de la boucle
organise de leur parcours d'art pour
l'occasion des artistes et artisans
d'art vous ouvrent les portes de leurs
ateliers
ça se passera le week-end des 5 et 6
juin notamment à houilles à
carrières-sur-seine chatou croissy sur
seine ou encore au vésinet et à monter
sont au programme peinture céramique pop
art ou encore broderie il imaginait le
monde de demain c'est ce que vous
propose le premier roman fiction de
romain rivière vision du futur et le
volet premier volet d'une trilogie un
futur proche dont l'histoire se passe à
paris un parallèle entre deux avenirs
possibles l'un virtuel et l'autre en
symbiose avec la nature
romain rivière auteur donc deux visions
du futur nous parle de son roman
[Musique]
c'est une utopie parce qu'il ya un
premier cadre qui est suivie d'un pari
2050 un pari vert ou le monde y est
totalement en symbiose avec son
environnement la société les humains et
l'environnement sont totalement en
symbiose avec la ville qui autogène
autogénérés soins sa propre énergie et
de l'autre côté il ya un petit peu plus
dystopique où on est dans un monde
totalement numérisée déshumanisée où tu
mens de vie dans le virtuel
c'est vraiment dire la vision des tubes
de l'été de vision il y en a qui est
dans une vision qui dans votre vision
mais là quelle est la réelle voilà ça
c'est à nous de choisir me suis basé sur
qui sur des choses très concrètes
je me suis donné sur les travaux de
vincent callebaut aucun architecte
français qu'a imaginé plusieurs versions
plusieurs villes dont paris 2050 vert
donc voilà j'ai voulu aurait cherché un
petit peu quelque chose qui serait
possible c'est ma vision à moi je dis
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait être quelque
peu comment pour être le monde de demain
et de façon dont j'imagine lequel on va
choisir c'est vraiment un objectif qui
était derrière c'est vraiment une
question à questionnement voulez vous
les posez un questionnement inventive
mounir le livre est sorti en décembre
2020 il a été réédité en mars 2021
il est disponible sur amazon et sur le
site de l'auteur dont le lien s'affiche
en bas de l'écran et c'est la fin de ce
numéro du 7-8 culture merci à tous de
nous avoir suivi très bonne soirée à
tous et à bientôt sur télé 78
[Musique]
oh